ayant déjà tout dit sur le maître
marionnettiste cheikh guèye chez trnka
nouveau revenir à présent un peu en
arrière et en 1908 c'est en france
précisément que naquit le film de
marionnettes avec le pionnier emile cole
qui allait les à plusieurs films mais
c'est une vingtaine d'années plus tard
que le polonais d'origine
ladislas starewitch après avoir
travaillé longtemps à moscou où il
réalisa quelques fils de me de poupées
animées sur les insectes vint
s'installer à paris et mis une dizaine
d'années à réaliser son film de 2200
mètres environ le roman de renart
c'est un très beau film un film qui
donne à la marionnette ses lettres de
noblesse en france un film dans lequel
le fab lio bien connu est racontée avec
une grande minutie une grande précision
et la cour du roi lion décrite avec ses
nombreux animaux